ونواصل من مصر حيث قررت محكمه جنايات امن
الدوله احاله مرشد جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
في مصر محمد بديع وسبعه من قاده الجماعه
الى مفتي الجمهوريه لابداء رايه الشرعي في
حكم الاعدام لادانتهم في قضيه احداث
المنصه التي تعود وقائعها لعام 2013
وحددت المحكمه جلسه في العشرين من سبتمبر
المقبل للنطقي في القضيه التي يحاكم فيها
79 متهما من قاده جماعه الاخوان ومن ابرز
المحالين الى المفتي اضافه الى المرشد
العام للاخوان كل من محمود عزت القائم
باعمال المرشد ومحمد البلتاجي وعمرو زكي
واوسام ياسين وصفوت حجازي كما احيل ايضا
كل من القيادي بالجماعه الاسلاميه عاصم
عبد الماجد والداعيه السلفي محمد عبد
المقصود الذين يحاكمان غيابيا في هذه
القضيه